This is bordering on I think they're having some sort of affair.
I need to like unblock myself un
Freudian unblack bill myself on things. I'm pretty sure Charlie
Kirk was like totally in love with her. Charlie Kirk was the
first casualty of the war in Iran. I'm certain of that and it's
deeper than that. I am now What?
Candace Candace Candace. Okay. I saw it straight up it was covered
in this.
>> And it's uh it's
it's pretty crazy, okay? We might be able to spin this. We could
probably take this stream in a totally different direction and
do like unironic spooky Sunday type content cuz she's going to
go into some crazy here, okay? We're going to talk about the
occult. We're going to talk about tons of awesome stuff, all
right?
Just totally awesome stuff. Okay, we're just going to pause our
bride of Charlie series just for one day because there's just
so much going on right now. Iran is literally on fire. Bill Ackman
wants me imprisoned apparently for suggesting that American sons
and daughters should object to being slaughtered for Israel.
Why why so
Perhaps because this entire war has been engineered by Israel.
Maybe it's that. Tucker Carlson, he is trending right now. By
the way, he's trending always. He what he is doing right now
is so remarkable and so brave and he is challenging the conversation
changing our understanding about the way politics works. And
he has just been so objectively honest and again brave in what
he is doing. But he's trending right now for a rather obscure
reason. It was actually a simple tweet that has a lot of his
routine haters melting down. This is the tweet. I'll show you
He wrote, "Pray that the spell breaks and the world is saved."
That's all he wrote. Of course we should we should pray. What
what is what is triggering them about that? I think I know. I
think it's the term a spell.
Yeah, a spell because a spell implies
some sort of witchcraft or magic is at work. And the timing of
this tweet
is Joe liberal? No. Okay. By the way, that's like a that's a
harbinger of things to come, okay? We're not We're not going
to be talking about religion. We're not going to be talking about
politics.
We're going to be talking about something different. >> really
is something because I have had it on my heart and on my mind
all weekend to find the right words to convey to my audience
that what is going on in this world is literally and exactly
that. People that practice occult magic are in this moment pushing
for World War III. And I think that's hard for a lot of people
to process because we you know, we grow up and we learn that
there are in effect really three major
uh religions in the West. So uh the idea that actually there
are people that are in charge of Western governments that are
in essence really pagan and could be making literal blood sacrifices
to various demons, that kind of evades us. It evades our understanding
of the world because Dude, Alex Jones won. And even more even
more than Alex Jones winning, okay?
Dude, okay. I said this in Shrader's chat. I don't think she
quite got what I was going for, but she kind of got it. Dude,
Zerkaa literally if Zerkaa had just like stayed sober and been
able to make content for like 2 years, for him to like become
for him to be like a consistent
hallmark of content creation in this era right now, dude, Zerkaa
would feast. He would make so much money cuz he was he's actually
charismatic. He knows all of the background and all of the occult
stuff. He knows all the background and all of the the what do
you call it? The
uh the cult stuff, the Freemason stuff, the Jesuits, the
I I don't know if he knew the franc stuff. I never heard him
talk about that, but he knows like a ton of this, right? Bro,
he could have he could have been doing this whole schizo thing
and making sh- the money. It would have been nuts. we look at
Hollywood, we look at culture. Hollywood in particular has been
ever intentional
Since when are Jesuits the occult? I think the Jesuits are
basically it's not it's like there's some occult element of the
Jesuits that run the CIA, I think. That it's all Jesuit symbology,
like the people who run the intelligence stuff in the US.
Is like is the conspiracy. in assisting sort of the implausibility
of such a narrative, right? Movies, books that are published.
If they delve into the topic of witchcraft and spellcasting,
it's reserved really for the category of fantasy, right? It's
fantasy if they're discussing it or it's being mocked. Hocus
pocus or Harry Potter, really. What sort of crazy person would
believe that ancient pagan practices are still happening in the
real world? Okay, maybe in some remote third world village in
but in the develop- Um don't bring up John Kirakou here. That
that guy I don't know what kind of op that guy is, but he's just
like a who's It's like everything he says is worthless. Totally
discounting that person, totally like deleting anything they
say from your mind is probably critical to having some sort of
objective analysis of the world.
>> developed Western world at the tippy top of government.
Take for example this recent Paris Fashion Show Collection
from a brand known as Matière Fécale. Just so you know, that
translates to fecal matter.
Wow, must have really been an inspired
show. Fecal matter. Wow, no, so in your face, but don't you take
it the next step further
and think that, you know, these people could be into some dark
stuff. That would make you, again, a crazy person.
What about the the much-celebrated visual artist to the stars,
the Serbian one? She's also an artist to the the politician.
She does spirit cooking. Literally, that was what was in those
Marina Abramović.
She puts on performances in front of the most powerful people.
Isn't it
Ab- How did she just say Abramović?
Candace is like hilariously uncultured and uneducated. It's very,
very funny. I don't say that because of her race. I just say
that because of everything about her, okay? She is like hilariously
I Bro, she must be looked at as a total barbarian in those British
like royal
Like like the guy who married her, and I I swear it's not a race
thing, but it's like they must look at her as like a total
peasant who's in those circles. Like just no education, nothing
going on
She puts on performances in front of the most powerful people
in the world. Performances like in 1974,
when she sought to, quote, re-evoke Yes, >> the energy
of extreme bodily pain, She married a royal. Her father Her father-in-law
is a lord, yeah, as as people are saying. It's like British In
British high society, it just must be like totally marrying down.
using a large
which the artist lit on fire at the start of the performance,
standing outside of the pentagram, um Abramović cut her nails,
her toenails, and her
When she finished with each, she threw the clippings into the
flames, creating a burst of light each time, burning the pentagram,
representing a physical and mental purification.
Oh, uh wow. That's just art, guys. That's just art. Don't you
think it step for No, come on. That's just art. And on the matter
of science, even when it's in our faces, like when the world's
leading nuclear physicists are caught cloaked before a statue
of Shiva stabbing a woman in a cult ceremony for
Is this CERN? Love this CERN. This CERN very cool.
I don't know. Was that a prank video? I'm pretty sure it's a
prank video. I think we've watched it here before.
Well, you guys, that's just science.
That right there that you are looking at on your screens
was science, the best science, the best that science has to offer,
the most ingenious people.
And indeed, I would agree that it is it's modern science. In
fact, the entire thrust of what was deemed the scientific revolution,
a move away from the natural order of things and towards empiricism,
rationality,
that began because of a long organized Freemasonic effort to
remove humanity from our innate spiritual understanding. Okay?
They wanted you to know that you can now ignore your God-given
instincts. You can set aside your subconscious. That subconscious
that comes online and lets you know that something is not right.
Yeah, you can just set that aside and and trust the experts instead.
Is this where Young gets his notes from? I don't know if he gets
them I I'm sure there's something upstream of Candace that he
gets it from.
Got to be, right? Or are you talking about he gets them from
like the Abramović stuff? So, I'm not totally
This is like National Treasure levels of conspiracy posting.
No, no, no, no, no, BB poisoned.
Just wait. We're what five We're barely 5 minutes into this video,
okay? It gets so so so so so much worse. It's actually it gets
hilariously worse, okay? >> back the experts constantly
reinforce to us that our subconscious our subconscious is wrong.
Or it's just weird. And in some cases it's immoral. It's devilish
even. You want to go see your grandmother while she's dying in
the middle of COVID? What are you Satan? You're being guided
by Satan.
If you don't listen to Dr. Fauci, that's who you're being guided
by. Cuz there's no greater source of authority in their world
than the government, which they This is like um
There are things going on under the surface here that are very
similar to someone like Fuentes, right? This thing where you
say things like intentionally wrong sort of filtering down to
people who will just believe you. You're you're like destabilizing
people's, you know, foundation in the world to get them to believe
you. You become their their like only hallmark of truth.
There is there is a lot of that going on. I think she she's mostly
just riffing off of what of other people what other people have
done, right? the control. That's the idea.
And I promise you on everything, like on everything, that when
Savannah, my manager, came down the stairs and delivered the
news that Charlie had been shot, Um the Destiny thing's very
different in the way he approaches it. Destiny's like very much
deconstructing other people who are like larger sources of authority.
This is sort of like This is working off of intuition in a reactionary
way. Destiny's not reactionary in the way he does it. It's like
a very different way of approaching it. This is like basically
trying to say like you you and your gut know something is wrong
and here's what's wrong. I'm taking some discomfort you feel
about the world. I'm taking your like reactionary tendency and
how it's being suppressed and I'm using that to explain to you
why it's being suppressed and why you feel offput by the world,
why you feel put off by the world, why you feel like discomfort,
right? It's very different. I went into my husband's office and
I cried and I immediately said to him,
he was betrayed. Charlie was betrayed.
And my husband said back to me, you don't know that. We don't
know anything yet. And I said, I know.
Now, empirically,
that argument fails. I get it. But no one can explain why or
how I had the sense of dread in the very week leading up to Charlie's
assassination. No one can offer why I knew that there was danger
coming specifically to a school. And why I felt that it was related
to bees, why the feeling was so overwhelming The bee keeper dream.
>> that I hired extra security and took my podcast off
air and pulled my children out of school. I had never experienced
a dread like that in my life, ever. No one also can ex- Dude,
I I'm suddenly having like a whole thing where this is connected
to like people in my real life and a family member who do like
um some of the spirituality stuff and I'm I'm cringing, dude.
I'm cringing, dude.
>> It's so [__] annoying.
explain or even offer an explanation as to how exactly it is
that Charlie knew he was going to die young. And that his death
would specifically be related to Turning Point USA. I he said
he knew from the moment he signed on the dotted line
that he was going to die young.
What exactly is is the expert explanation for that deep internal
knowing that he had that has now been proven correct?
I'll tell you there isn't one. There isn't one. But Charlie's
sense was obviously right. And the moment that Charlie was shot,
I knew what happened to him was not random, okay? He was betrayed.
Charlie Kirk was the first casualty of the war in Iran. I'm certain
of that and it's deeper than that. I am now What?
Wait, what? Hold on.
Charlie Kirk was the
first casualty of the war in Iran and she's certain of that.
now of the opinion, hm, but he was likely sacrificed and
I want to tell you why I got there. You guys know if you're part
of my book club, I've been doing a lot of research into Freemasonry.
About um a month ago while we took a break to prepare for our
Bride of Charlie series, someone sent me this. I'm showing you
this is what they sent me in the mail. Something that is known
as a Freemason Bible. Now, I knew that these existed uh because
of my studying Sigmund Freud and looking into the fact that he
had inherited one from his father.
Uh the back story of this one in particular, it came with a handwritten
letter, is that a 33rd
degree Freemason out in Oklahoma died and all of his belongings
were left in a home that was eventually auctioned off. And the
person who who had this in his possession, his relative was the
person who acquired the home. This is like definitely I I just
feel like I'm imagining this is Zerka sending this to Candace
Owens. And they went in and they burnt everything in it effectively.
Uh It looks like it was made last week. It does look very new,
doesn't it? Hold on. It does look very new. That looks like a
brand new like book binding, right? Maybe there's a little wear
here at the edge. That looks like a very new book binding though.
>> knew that these existed uh because of my studying Sigmund
Freud and looking into the fact that he had inherited one from
his father.
Uh the back story of this one in particular, it came with a handwritten
letter, is that a 33rd degree Freemason out in Oklahoma died
and all of his belongings were left in a home that was eventually
auctioned off. And the the who who had this in his possession,
his relative was the person who acquired the home. And they went
in and they burned everything in it effectively
thinking that it was obviously just carrying bad
But he for some reason had the sense that he should keep this
one item. For no particular reason he kept it in the back of
his truck for over a decade and when he saw me covering the history
of Freemasonry
and what they believe trying to discern what is it they believe,
he felt that this was the
that he had kept it all those years. So he just sent it to me.
To to provide me further insight into
what they believe and what they practice at the top of Freemasonry.
This is not your granddad's Freemason Lodge, okay? That is not
Uh,
dude. Sorry, this just got posted in my Discord. It's [snorts]
very real. He's my schizo internet poster. I'm watching him.
No, I'm his handler. I'm in love with him. Oh, the internet We
have to be reaching critical mass on the internet, right? I feel
like there's like a certain direction the internet is going that
we just have to be hitting critical mass at this point. There's
got to be something happening here
where like we're reaching the end of something. You know what
I'm saying? We're we're just about at the end. We got to be close
to the end. We got to be We we have to be, don't we? No, my dad
was a lodge. It was just a No, this is not that. That is not
what a 33rd degree Freemasonry is.
So I flipped through this immediately
after we did throw down it in holy water, I flipped through it.
And within the very first pages there was a
with various illustrations inside of it, notes around it. I'm
going to show you that now. I just took a picture for it for
you to see it.
Um, there at the bottom and in case you can't see what is pointing
to the middle, it says place of sacrifice
or
Place of sacrifice or worship in the middle there. >> I
want you to know that in this Freemason Bible it illustrates
that a sacrifice must be made in the center of
a pentagon. That's a pentagon. Five sides.
Like a house.
It's not a pentagon, it's a pentagram,
A A pentagon
it's a five-pointed star. It's not a What what?
Hold on.
Objectively, oh, sorry. No, no, no. It is a pentagon. I see what
she's The center of the star is within a pentagon. Okay. No,
I was correcting and I'm I was wrong. >> A sacrifice must
be made in the center
a pentagon. That's a pentagon. Five sides.
Like a house.
And I thought how curious that Charlie was indeed seated in the
center of a pentagon
when he was killed. Let me demonstrate that for you. You can
see that right there. That's not a pentagon.
I don't A pentagon Is a pentagon any
uh polygon? I don't think so, right? Pentagon would be like equilateral
like an equilateral
polygon, right? Again, it was my independent study into Sigmund
Freud that led me to learning about B'nai B'rith, the Freemason
group who I believe have been running our country since at least
the Civil War. I've done my best to consume and learn about what
it is that they believe, what they practice. This is a cult mysticism,
okay? The satanic Bro, I think like this is like the real reason
for the I I feel bad because I participate.
But like our
our like need for entertainment is what destroys the economy.
Like if we were just, you know, go work in a factory or something.
Don't listen to this stuff anymore. Don't try to be one of these
people. Just go work in a factory, okay? I know there are no
factory jobs. I know, but it's like dude, this is this is what
Americans do instead of having a productive economy in any way
is we like watch Candace Owens, we talk about Candace Owens,
we react to Candace
Come on, man. >> Panic, panic that happened was real. Children
are being harmed. They have been harmed in occult ceremonies
for a very long time. This is an ancient
And this is not to be confused with Judaism in any way. In fact,
they rely on you confusing it. In no shape or form does this
have anything to do with any of the monotheistic religions, okay?
Judaism is merely a mask that these pagan occultists wear, just
like Christianity is one of the masks that they wear.
The star of David, as they term it, is in fact an occult symbol
meant to represent King Solomon's ring. There is no way that
you can avoid this. There's no way that they can try to rewrite
history. It is quite literally What?
King Solomon, I love King Solomon. Really known as the seal of
Solomon. I'm going to show you this. This is you can This is
on Wikipedia. This is that
We can read parts of this together. It reads, "It is often depicted
in the shape of either a hexagram or a pentagram. In mystic
lore, the ring is variously dis- I don't I feel like it's not
a pentagram anywhere. I don't know
the I've never seen it described as a
anywhere. A hexagram, yes. A pentagram, never. Where is it a
pentagram?
Sorry, it says hexagram or pentagram, but it's
I It's like a hexagram every hexagram every hexagram a hexagram
every time. described as having been given to Solomon the having
given Solomon, pardon me, the Like I think the fact that they
are equilateral triangles
within an equilateral like pointed polygon creating all these
equilateral elements inside, I think this is all like important.
Right? This is all important to like the the symbology. Like
all of these things break down to different types of The power
to command the supernatural.
Due to the proverbial wisdom of Solomon, it came to be seen as
an amulet or a talisman or a symbol or character in
just said amulet.
Get this. Get this woman a Snickers. She is hungry, okay?
A five egg omelette, okay? >> magic. In Renaissance magic,
occultism,
Ladies and gentlemen, this is literal
We cannot beat these people and we cannot win if we refuse to
even recognize what it is that we are up against. We have to
recognize what it is and who it is that we are up against. And
again, it has nothing to do with
It's got nothing to do with Judaism.
That is why, as is further stipulated on this Wikipedia page,
the Seal of Solomon was once featured on the flag of
And the flag Did they really just put Nigeria here? Is this a
thing? They just put Nigeria here? They just wrote Nigeria in
That's like a flag, man. It was already a flag,
but they just wrote Nigeria under the crown. Flag of Morocco.
Those are not known to be
Freemasons worship Solomon as the master architect. They believe
that he gave them the keys to build and therefore control societies.
This is how you build This is how you build a matrix in effect,
right?
That is the reason why Aleister Crowley,
who was a master occultist, created an entire religion around
this, put together a series of books, a series of pentacles that
are meant to summon various spirits. I want you to hear me when
I say that they are intentionally
summoning demons.
First book he wrote was called the book of evil spirits. Wow,
look at that star of David all over it. The Lesser Key of Solomon,
Goetia, the evil the book of evil spirits.
Lemegeton, Clavicula Salomonis Regis.
What do you What do you mean this is not associated with Judaism?
It's associated with Baal worship. I cannot stress this enough.
That That is what those in power practice. It is what they believe.
>> way, B A A L, Baal Baal Baal. She's not talking about
She's not talking about bowel movements, okay? Baal Baal. >> ancient.
It is a cult and it is magic.
I believe that the manner of Charlie's death Charlie's death
was also intended to cast a spell.
It's the only thing I come up I kept asking the question, why
did they broadcast this?
Making us watch Charlie die was
And although this priest that I'm about to show you is discussing
Satanism more broadly, he's not saying this to be clear in the
context of Charlie Kirk. I want you to take a listen to what
he says. This is Father Ripperger. He is going to describe the
nature of this sort of constant
symbolism that's being used, this obsession
with them almost having to reveal to us what they're doing, like
wanting to get close to revealing to us what they're doing, and
then gaslighting us. Take a listen.
Actually, the uh the technical term that we tend to use for that
is called the revealing of the method.
I don't know if you've ever heard of that. Basically, it's um
it basically means that This is like um
this all runs into
Man, I I could if I ever wanted to look at his conspiracy stuff,
I feel like I could do this one, too.
Revealing of the method. I feel like this is the whole thing
you get into like how in mythology a lot of like a lot of things
that want to own you, own your soul, control you in some way,
they need to be invited to do it. So, you have to have their
consent. And so, the reason you like reveal the method over time
is so that you get their consent, right? As long as you're showing
people what you're doing, then they are going to be consenting.
You have to get You have to get them to to acknowledge and accept
these things that are happening. Yeah, you have to invite the
vampire into your house, exactly. Exactly.
it can be connected to a curse. They could like they could curse
this so that it has a more uh so that its distribution becomes
more extensive and more people watch the thing. Um but a lot
of times what that is is that they The thing about Satanists
and also even though it's occult in the fact that it's hidden,
there is still There's a a side to diabolic psychology
that even when they're remain hidden, they still want to show
themselves in some way. They still want They're still going to
reveal themselves in something. They can't help it. And it's
the same thing you see It's the same thing you see with Satanists.
It's the same thing you see with um Freemasons when they're involved
in certain things. It's the same stuff you see across the board
in these uh in these particular um groups. And so, they they
just tend to reveal stuff. Um but their hope is to even in the
revealing that you don't know. There's a sadistic delight they
get out of basically putting it to you without you even knowing
it. Ah, I don't Ah, I don't like that direction. Candace, don't
go that direction. It They need you to accept. It's important
that you listen to me because I'm going to immunize you so you
don't just accept these things. So, you don't just walk into
these things unknowingly because you are selling parts of your
soul every time you make these decisions, okay? So, I'm I'm to
save your soul. I'm here to help you. That's the direction you
should go in, Candace. Not whatever direction that I'm talking
about. Yes. That is accurate. It is diabolical,
and they are clearly sadistic in what they are doing. And of
course, there is an element of it they enjoy to gaslight you
right after they do these sorts of
Uh that piece, by the way, about the the symbolism, sort of overt
and in your
is also made clear in the very early pages of this
Freemason Bible. That symbolism is actually crucial. In fact,
it's a science to that
You're not imagining things. Right here at the top, it states
this.
Again, from this   Freemason Bible.
It reads, "It has been correctly stated that symbolism constitutes
the very essence of Freemasonry. Freemasonry is essentially the
science of symbolism."
Further down, it it offers us a sec- Dude, I think about stuff
like this sometimes in terms of like, if I actually wanted to
grow as a streamer, there would be a lot of work you would do
outside of streaming. In fact, I might need to put more work
outside of streaming than actually streaming. The streaming stuff
I actually think I've got down. I realize people will joke about
not wanting to watch or whatever. I think I could actually put
together a pretty entertaining stream. I'm not That's not really
my concern anymore. But building up like branding and stuff,
building up um building up branding, building up like the direction
you want to go in, there's a lot of stuff that I think I think
I could plan this out and come up with a direction that would
work very well, but it feels overtly manipulative. And it's not
it like this makes me think of that cuz I like to think of it
in terms of like
I want to basically
I want to find a way to sort of like hit on a topic or go in
a direction that's valid from like multiple different perspectives.
And symbology's like one way to do it. It's you want people to
like agree with you and feel validated in agreeing with you from
multiple different like basically people have different points
of authority in their lives. Like let's say for for like it to
ground this sort of is like let's say you watch like Sam Harris
and
Destiny
and Hasan [__] Well, what do those people agree on
and how do I include elements in the things I talk about that
would basically get you to go oh I've heard this guy talk about
this topic before and I think he's smart and now this guy saying
some of the same things. Oh wow, he's like
Thank you very much Reuben Reuben. So
it's it's not tricking women into it's like how do you talk about
topics and reinforce your opinion use like what people already
believe in to reinforce the things you're saying. So they go
and they you don't say you don't reference the stuff like directly
you say things that basically
you know other
reinforcement mechanisms help, right? And I kind of do the opposite
of that. The Hasan is bad thing is like an opposite thing, right?
We're explicitly working against the the whole
that whole idea.
Right? Yeah, exactly Evil Johnny Bravo. But I I just I don't
spend a lot of time thinking about this. I I'm trying to think
of some time I've done it.
You're just describing Moist Critical. No, no, no, no, no, it's
very different than Moist Critical. Moist Critical is like that
maximally applied in a way
how do I describe it? Moist Critical is like maximally applying
that in a way that like you almost say nothing. It's like what
would those people not disagree with? It's like a different way
of looking at it. What would all of these people not not call
me out for? That's a different thing. Rather than saying what
do these people like sort of deeply believe and preach and how
do I take an element of that and work it into something I'm saying.
It's it's a different thing that's going on. Have your own gravy
per Pepe. No, it's not like that. Uh let's see. J Soc does the
Hassan laugh. Sorry. He's got other laughs. I should learn some
of the other laughs. Section entitled the sign Just do it like
once a week and see how it goes. Unfortunately, it comes down
to some of my I have to un-black pill myself somehow, okay?
I have to un-black pill myself to go in this to go in like some
direction like
And I don't know how to do it. >> means of symbolism explained.
It reads, "A symbol or an emblem is an occult representation
of Right now, I just do the the joking and okay, I do the joking
around and and it's fun.
I need to like un-black myself uh un- God. Uh Freudian un-black
pill myself on things. God damn it.
I should just end this stream there. Dude, I should JUST END
THE NO!
NO!
OKAY, THE PENGUIN THE penguin is done. We need a new we need
a new thing. We need a new channel.
Could be Oh, why did I say that? Un-black pill myself.
To go in a direction like this and figure out what we want to
do. God Something unknown or concealed by a sign or a thing that
is >> Shouldn't stream shouldn't stream late after like
just waking up after being up for like 28 hours. Shouldn't be
doing it, man. It's crazy.
Something you recognize kind of carrying
different deeper meaning different
And it gives us some examples. Incredibly, you're you wouldn't
believe me if I didn't show it to you. It gives the example of
a square. A square is in Freemasonry an emblem or a symbol of
morality.
A plumb line, the the symbol of rectitude, and the beehive as
a symbol of industry.
Yes, they do communicate to one another using symbols as I have
maintained from the very beginning. By the way, Cash Patel continually
stressing 33 hours was not random. It did not feel subtle. It
seemed to me and to many others that was some sort of signaling.
33 33 everyone was just saying 33 all the time.
So to the routinely gaslit public, I would like to validate validate
your every instinct most especially about the subsequent behavior
of Turning Point USA as an organization, behavior that looked
to us as though it was diabolical.
There was apparently, sadly for them, not enough empiricism,
rationality, or spell casting in the universe to override our
sense that something was and is deeply wrong. Deeply.
Okay, deeply wrong.
What did they give us? The horrific murder of a man followed
by the joyful coronation of his wife
who is now inviting his enemies onto the very ship that he built?
Spiritual ick is what we felt. Okay? Words have meaning. They
sent out their
uh to cast something more broadly to the public. Yeah, that's
that is what broadcasters do. That She's RIGHT, THAT IS WHAT
BROADCASTERS DO. They cast things broadly to the pub-
Oh my god. What they cast was, she's a grieving widow. They sent
out their
effectively
uh to cast something more broadly to the public.
What they cast was, she's a grieving widow. That's what Charlie
would have wanted. 6-ft social distancing. To what end though?
To what end?
It's so awesome. I don't
It's just so awesome, okay? It's so
It's so awesome to watch that this works. How many views? 2.2
million views, dude. Again, I just think of that Nico or sorry,
the the Nick Fuentes post he did where he's like getting he's
seething about Candace Owens and like how hard he works and how
he had to be like the intellectual of the anti-Semitic movement.
And like Nick Nick Fuentes using like all of his power to do
like 1% of Candace Owens' powers which he's just like, "Charlie
came to me in a
"Charlie came to me wearing a beekeeper's outfit in a dream."
>> Nick Fuentes gives up his entire life, his education,
his entire future just to fight this movement and Candace Owens
is
"They cast things broadly to the public. They're like broadcasters."
And [laughter] everybody's like, "Oh my god, Candace, so true.
So true, Candace, so true."
It's so funny to me, dude. It's so funny that she's so powerful
with just two words. Two words just brought not even two words,
sorry. One word, broadcast, okay? It's just Candace Owens summed
up. She's so powerful. It's just concentrated, I don't know,
it's just concentrate It's just all gas, man. It's crazy.
I believe it's pretty obvious now
there was an ultimate goal of raising Erica's political profile
as a potential presidential candidate down the line, actually.
That was explicitly and almost
seated by her dear friend and part-time
deviant Tyler Boyer, who she can't remember how she met. Take
a listen to what he said a mere 12 days after >> Wait,
hold on, hold on, hold on.
I don't know how much of the straight raid stream I watched of
this. Where's the Where's the straight raid stream?
There was There was an ultimate goal of raising Erica's political
profile as a potential presidential candidate down the line,
actually. That was explicitly and almost immediately
seated by her dear friend and part-time homosexual deviant Tyler
Boyer, who she can't remember how she met. Take a listen to what
he said a mere 12 >> part-time homosexual deviant A couple
of after Charlie's assassination. Do you see I have one of those.
He came up He came on the stream and he was talking about this
thing called like Havana syndrome or something like that.
She knows she's going to get blown out of the Havana syndrome
thing, so she's she's already seating with her audience that
I'm wrong on it, okay? She's terrified of the Havana syndrome
conversation, so she's seating with her audience that I'm incorrect
or a part-time sexual deviant, okay? It's dumb. his assassination.
Do you see politics in her future down the road? Yeah, you know,
it's funny. I had had conversations with Charlie about that.
So, he he he was like, "Man, Erica could be so much bigger and
better than me at almost everything." We [laughter] talked We'd
laugh all the time about it cuz people were like, "Charlie could
was going to be president someday." He believed firmly that Erica
was going to be president someday. Well, there it is again. Them
telling us the private conversations were the exact opposite
of everything that Charlie was saying
Women, get married. Have children. Have lots of children. Stay
home. That's more important. Um in the days leading up, Erica
said she stayed back cuz Charlie said, "Home needs you." That's
why she didn't go to the September 10th event. They were just
on a tour. Speak Charlie was just every day telling people
that family is the most important thing, but privately, when
he sat down with Tyler Boyer, he was like, "Erica's going to
be president. That's what I want for my wife. I want my I want
her to be president and to be also the I Yeah, I just don't
That doesn't make any sense. I don't know whatever.
mother of his kids. Erica had like no profile at all. Why are
we pretending Erica was involved with with TPUSA in like any
sort of public-facing way?
That's kind of sweet. He could have maybe said something like
that, but like
it would be in the like, you know, platitude type of way. It
wouldn't be a sincere thing. Come on. >> CEO and chairman
in the event of my death. And, you know, he wasn't the only one
cuz it's you got to go backwards to really realize how deranged
everything was. Here is uh Frank Turik on October 7th, just 3
weeks following Charlie's assassination. Take a listen. I used
to say to him, "The ticket in 2028's going to be Vance Kirk."
And I said, "I don't know if you want to take it cuz I don't
think you're going to have the same effect as the president of
Turning Point USA."
But you know what? Between you and me and our listeners, I'm
not giving up on the Vance Kirk ticket.
Well, Amen. It's very exciting right there, but um I think uh
I think Erica would be an amazing president someday. That, my
friends, would be an example of what of a Father Rupnik described
diabolical
Oh. Charlie was going to be the president, but you know what?
It was Vance Kirk is what we were hoping for, now he's gone,
I just realized we don't have to let go
of the hope
cuz there's still a Kirk.
And there's still a President Vance. That could be
Does Why do conservatives like How do conservatives not immediately
look at everything Erica Kirk's done so far and just run in terror
at the total lack of like aura, presence, charisma,
everything? Like, how in the world do they cons- they continue
to pretend that Erica Kirk is a human being?
I think they do? Okay, well, some aren't. And Trump just named
her to some random [__]
So, I'm I'm just saying, like, it's it's crazy how quickly she
burned up all the goodwill Charlie Kirk had and then the the
goodwill generated from Charlie Kirk
Like, like, it's all gone already.
Really beautiful and exciting. Could be what Charlie wanted in
the end. And of course, here is the very and always excited Mikey
McQuaid echoing that sentiment. Take a listen. Mikey McQuaid.
>> behind these blueprints for her. And [clears throat]
just And for you. Yeah. there you go. >> And for you, Mikey.
Yeah, and uh
>> Yeah, I we don't really ever know what the outcome's
going to be. I I definitely thought maybe there would be a Vance
Kirk ticket, maybe there was still will be a Vance Kirk ticket.
Just beautiful, isn't it? How who could who could deny this sort
of a destiny, Erica can being the president in her husband's
place, and they're smiling, and they're laughing about that plausibility.
And we're never going to see those blueprints, guys, but they
did say to Mikey McCoy, my 21-year-old person who I I've no idea
how you even got this job as chief of staff, uh but the these
blueprints are for you. I didn't give you responsibly give them
to someone that was running my estate, lawyers. No, I wanted
to leave these for you and to Erica because I don't know, she
just would understand these
Well, I mean
I mean, that makes sense that he would leave them to Erica. Did
she She just says that with like total incredulity.
Why would she leave Why would Charlie leave like his plan for
his legacy to his wife? That's just insane. No, it's not really,
actually.
That's like his life partner, his wife, like that actually would
make sense. Even if she wasn't somebody he wanted to like run
everything, if he had some idea for like how to run after he
died, it makes total sense.
Does she Does she think they're actual blueprints? I mean, I
think
he probably believes they're directives, and and it's sort of
it's implied they're directives, but it could just be like, "Oh,
you know, he said things in day-to-day life that was like indications
of where he wanted the organization to go." Sure. With everything
that I have thus far uncovered about Erica, I do believe that
that was her ultimate goal, the White House. I think Elizabeth
Lane read Erica correctly when she posited that she may be a
psychopath because in my opinion, only a psychopath could, after
her husband's public assassination, offer a
This is bordering on I think they were having sort of affair.
I don't know if Candace Owens is like a
I'm pretty sure Charlie Kirk was like totally in love with her.
Where's the Can somebody find me the tweet cuz I'm not going
to go look it up while we do this. Can somebody find me the tweet
where she like puts out the text of Charlie talking to her and
he's basically like I feel like I'm a man out of time and I was
like searching through time just to find you and like and now
I found you you've like anchored me to this time and she's like
I feel like I'm an alien sometimes.
Dude. It's
No, no, no, you need to see their actual text messages where
she like he's he's literally like writing like a romance novel
to her and she's like I feel like I'm an alien sometimes. I feel
like I'm not from this planet sometimes.
I feel like I'm an alien. It's like dude, what the [__]
So, it's so goofy, man. To Dan Flood. The security guard who
failed Charlie in every possible manner and way on September
10th. Only a psychopath who does not experience human emotions
in the way that humans experience them would be capable of offering
and then giving an in-home interview to the New York Times in
the immediate day That's just women missing obvious signals.
I think it's her like being actually like some kind of some kind
of not sensing
But women would pick up that signal. Most women would pick up
that signal and and her response from other women would tell
me like oh, they have no interest in Charlie Kirk at all. Like
they're trying to totally play it off as if they don't understand
or they don't get what's going on at all. I think Candace Owens
is just genuinely like missing the signal. I think most women
would see that signal and be like yeah, I feel like I'm an alien
sometimes.
I don't know like what you I'm going to kind of like sidestep
what you just said and say something totally innocuous and like
change the subject.
He's following her husband's assassination. The New York Times,
a publication who her husband hated.
Who her husband hated.
And would then tell that journalist that the least traumatizing
part was the idea of raising her children without a
A psychopath is the best answer that I can come up with for why
she felt compelled to go into the office the same week and to
bring her kids every day rather than tending to their every emotional
need at home. As they come to the realization that they will
never see their father ever again. A psychopath is my best explanation.
My best explanation for why she told Jesse Watters
that she had zero fear. None at all. No, she wasn't scared to
walk out the door the very next day with her kids in tow.
I think nearly everyone in the world felt a little less safe
in the days following Charlie's assassination. Well, not his
wife Ericka Kirk. No. Mhm.
>> Ericka lies pathologically and the media is trying to
tell us that it's perfectly understandable, relatable even. It's
actually divine. She lies because she's so godly. So godly that
she forgave the person who allegedly murdered her husband before
she even saw evidence of his guilt. And despite an overwhelming
amount of evidence mounting to the contrary, Ericka is so godly
that she even helped to validate the implausible parts of the
regarding Tyler Robinson. The implausible parts
like the neck stopping a .30-06 bullet. She came up and crafted
the Superman steel neck and all. No question. Bro, she I Dude,
I don't give a [__] about Charlie Kirk and Ericka
Kirk. Is she really off of the There's no more demonic [__]
I thought there was more of the demonology stuff.
And to be sure, uh whatever the attempt was with Ericka, pay
attention to me media, it has failed categorically. So, stop
it. Okay? All of your little media spells are failing as of late
because we've recognized that they are very easily defeated by
truth, loud truth. And more and more people are daring to speak
it. More and more people are feeling inspired by Tucker Carlson
to stand up and to recognize what it is we are fighting in this
world, true evil. Old school, ancient evil.
We even have comedians that are daring to make jokes about the
obvious. The Wait. Okay, no, no, no. We're not done yet. I knew
I knew we weren't done yet. >> take a listen.
You know, you look at the the Kirk
Right? Remember that? You look at that
and you try to zoom out and go, all
Tragic death
on its face.
We don't we see a furry
the furry's boyfriend, the thing. Okay. Then we zoom out, we
go, wait, the wife's weird.
Something's up with the wife.
The organization's weird. Something's up with them.
You know, 3 weeks after the guy's dead, she's out there with
sparklers. You know, they're doing Cirque du Soleil. Something's
off. Something's weird.
Now we find out like
the wife is it's beyond weird, it's
And there's a very good chance that this woman was his handler.
That he was this powerful
young guy
who raised a lot of money for a a lot of people and took a lot
of money. >> Do we really do we really believe that Erica
Kirk is an actual handler?
Do we really believe this? Do we actually believe this?
Are people buying this? Like, honestly,
I mean, she's white trash. I don't know that she was like ever
like was she really that special?
I've got no indication. Why is she in that stupid music video
from so long ago? From a lot of people and and money's never
free. So, you think about it, you say, you have this How do you
How do you direct a guy like that who's
incredibly important. He's running the largest young voter,
you know, registration
uh organization.
He's handling large sums of money. He's out there sculpting
narrative as it regards to
domestic and foreign policy.
So, you have a handler
who comes in. And she may have loved him. I'm sure she loved
him. Why wouldn't a handler
love her husband?
Because even though she was his Mossad handler and probably had
him killed, no marriage is perfect. No. [laughter] Okay, Tim
says it's funny in this one, okay. I feel like this is he he
he's weaving memes into what he actually thinks, okay? >> Not
one mat No marriage is perfect,
Dude, no marriage is perfect. There's no marriage Yeah, like
she had him killed, but like come on.
You don't think your wife would have you killed for Israel? You
don't think that would happen? Come on, man. She may have been
his handler and they came to her one day and said, "He found
out you were his handler." Or she might have told them. She might
have said, "Listen, we got problems. This guy
and I'm not the only one saying this. Don't kill me. Uh there
I'm saying we're not breaking news here. We're not breaking ground.
WE'RE REVIEWING.
WE'RE ANALYZING.
WE'RE LIKE BEHIND THE EIGHT BALL.
THIS woman may have said called someone up and said, "We got
bad news here. This guy found all the laundered money and now
he knows I'm his handler and he thinks that invalidates the marriage.
Because I'm his handler.
They were like, can we do anything about it? Is there Is there
anything we can do here? And she goes, I don't know. And then
they go, well, you know, we might have to, you know.
And she cried
and she was sad.
Whatever. And I'm not saying any of that happened. I'm saying
that's more reasonable
what kind of we're being told.
That's all. And of course he is correct. There's absolutely nothing
that we're being told is reasonable whatsoever. It doesn't make
any sense.